you know
there is this real cool picture you
showed of your entire family it was like
two cousins
grandpa aunt auntie can you talk i mean
assume the audience is looking at the
picture right now
talk about the picture that you have
with your family jumping yeah so my
family's got
you know i grew up on it when i was 16
it wasn't uh
so much of if you were gonna jump it's
wind you know as soon as i was able we
jumped right in there
and i was the older of a bunch of my
cousins so we all started skydiving as
we got bigger and bigger
uh we started jumping more and more and
most people you go play sports at high
school
at the end of the day you'd zip back
over jump back into skydiving pack
parachutes to make more jumps
and it was kind of like a family
business if you worked at a restaurant
you're a busboy
uh in our family you pack parachutes
[Music]
it's it's similar to my conversation
with wallanda where he said seventh
generation they walked on wire rope
tight ropes and that's what they did for
a living and that was their family thing
but
do you do you notice a common thread or
a common trend
with people that you run into that are
obsessive
or or love jumping as much as you do is
there a commonality
yeah what i think it does is skydiving
gives you a freedom whether you're a
world-class skydiver or someone who just
made a jump or two
and you have this common bond you find
this small group of people that not very
many people in the world have
experienced what you have
and it kind of draws you in and it it
kind of consumes your life and it
becomes part of
you have this bond that not many people
have of jumping out of an airplane
together i mean
in the world you know maybe there's 300
000 people who've made a skydive
including one jump
you know and that's a very small group
of people on the planet that have gotten
to feel what you do
so i think it draws you in and then you
just want to get some people have a
competitive spirit you want to just go
go go and be a
world-class competitor or you just want
the freedom of a guy on the weekend
going out to the y and playing
basketball with their friends it's the
same thing with skydiving just a little
more adventurous
yeah there seems to be a very common
personality
on how they are and you know what what
you know
it's very interesting when i run into
them i have friends that are just die
hard jumpers and they can't get enough
of it
they can't wait for the next one that's
like they're feeding it it's like an
addict i gotta have my next jump i get i
get that feeling about him but
since your jump that you had you know
the year roger bannister broke the
record a four-minute mile you know they
say oh when he ran broke the four-minute
mile
30-something people did it the following
year ever since
you jumped without a parachute how many
people have done it since you
uh nobody no see that's what's crazy
about it
that's what's crazy about this record
luke i mean i know for you
you know you're the person that did it
we're the audience okay so there's
there's 7.7 billion people in the world
a lot of people can
can say they climb mount everest a lot
of people can say they did a lot of
different there's many billionaires in
the world
there are four trillion dollar companies
in the world there's only one
let me say the proper adjective
courageous
guy there's only one
courageous guy that jumped out of a
plane 25
000 feet 250 220 pounds going 120 miles
an hour with 200 feet at the bottom
that was willing to do